[Music]
hello you two just love us in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
50th episode of dirty tricks in the 2
now in practice if you come across a
person who is regularly employed 3 c3
model against your favorite Sicilian
then this video will provide you a great
shock weapon the line I have presented
here not only contains lots of tricks
but if white is not careful then just
within the opening stage the game can be
decided very quickly after efore sefa
and Knight to f3 the setup I am going to
recommend here is hyper exited dragon
which start with g6 after as expected
response 3 C 3 which has a clear
intention to grab the center we are
going to respond this with a very calm
Bishop to g7 ok white is more than happy
as he is going to get the center
immediately with D foo and after C
captors d4 and C captures D fool you can
easily see that white obtained a very
good centre but no matter this is
exactly black ones because now we are
going to hit back the centre with this
thematic secede and break D Phi so
immediately white has to decide whether
he wants to capture on D Phi or push
forward with E Phi the most popular
choice here is Aoife and that we are
going to look in detail however if your
opponent continues with he kept his D
Phi then I believe that after Knight to
f6 not only black regained the pawn with
his Knight but later on white get this
ice
d porn which can become a clear-cut
target in the middle game you can easily
search this position in database and
find out how easily black and play
against the system
however our big concern is what happens
here
white expand with ePHI grab every single
space at the center of the ball and
asking black what your bishop is doing
on g7 well to some extent that's true
but on the other side of the coin black
has a clear target namely this d4 pawn
and every single piece are now going to
aim the d4 square which believe it or
not gives black a good counter play in
this opening here black has many choice
but the most important move you should
remember is Bishop to g4 pinning down
the night thus pressurizing the d4
square now if you check this position in
online database you will find out that
there are two popular responses here
from the white one is Bishop to b5 check
which I personally don't like as black
and simply play Knight to d7 and I have
attached a model game in the PGN which
will give you a very good idea how
easily black plays in such a lines
however we are going to concentrate on
the other popular choice by white namely
a combination of two moves Knight to c3
and Bishop to e2 and I must tell you
that with my own experience whenever I
reach this position majority of my
opponent choose this setup as it is rock
solid and some way very natural to the
white camp so let's check out what kind
of problem Vikon faced when he goes for
this popular line
Knight to c3 Knight to c6
so threat is very simple we want to play
Bishop captures f3 and if Queen takes
then d4 pawn drops so by force White has
to take with the pawn which results in a
bad pawn structure
so accordingly white continue with
Bishop to e2 and blacks next move is
very obvious night to at six so you can
see that Knight is heading towards FY
square where it pressurized more on d4
square so accordingly White has to play
h3 at this position if he castles then
it will transpose to the line which we
are going to look in detail but let's
check out the most critical move s3 and
after that there is no second thought
yup you are going to capture on f3 and
after Bishop captures f3 for a time
being we cannot play Knight to a5 as our
d5 pawn hangs so we need to protect it
with a six and we reach to one of the
critical junction of this line here
White has two choices amongst them if he
continued with the MU g4 which at first
sight looks so great because it
restricting this night however after G
fool the problem in the white campus
he can never castle on the King side and
King is never safe on the Queen side
where on the counter part black and
simply play castle and quick f6 which
gives him a very good attacking chances
on the White King I have attached a
sample line in the PGA which will give
you a very good idea how to play against
this move g4 the more natural for the
white player is to castle on the Kings
side safe on the king and the same time
we are going to castle on the Kings side
which sets the platform for big upcoming
trick now as per the data base there are
three moves has been tried but against
each of them black has some nasty reply
which finish of the white at the opening
stage the first ball I want to consider
is Bishop to e3 which is a reasonable
move protecting the d4 and completing
the piece development however it doesn't
stop automatic plan Knight to a5 not
only hitting the d4 but same time if
flack wish he can continue with Knight
captures III just to illustrate my point
in one of the high level game a 2400
rated opponent continue from here Queen
to d2 which looks very natural white
aiming for the move Bishop to g5 and
Queen to b6 is not a threat because what
can easily defend with rook to d1
however believe it or not after Black's
next reply white instantly get a losing
position before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out that super
mu which literally kills the white well
we are going to witness one of the most
amazing trick in this line which happens
after black's super reply ab6
what a move when idea is very simple
black is going to grab a pawn and the
problem here for the white campus he
cannot defend on the e5 square and the
most initial response in the world he
kept his f6 fails due to the simple move
Queen kept his AB 6
and suddenly there are four attack
unleashed on the d4 square and even if
white wishes he cannot defend the d4
pawn and in fact the game so that is one
of the trademark trick in this line
which you should always watch out play
the MU epsilon y --d capsule captured
with the Queen and suddenly the d4 pawn
is doomed to the death you can see the
rest of the game where 2400 struggles
and after all he resigned in just mere
29 moves well apart from Bishop to e3
what happens if white plays other moves
well the impact is more or less same for
example white can continue here with g4
which once again restricting the Knight
to f5 idea by black but what it doesn't
stop it yup the typical freeing break AB
6 and after he captures f6 and Queen
captures AB 6 not only black is hitting
the poor bishop
but once the bishop moves then we can
simply NAB this pawn and black emerged
with a clear-cut advantage probably the
most critical move here is Bishop to g4
which has a simple idea that if Knight
comes to Fr then white Bishop will chop
it off however even against this black
has some nasty tricks in the back first
of all black is going to capture this
mission and after Queen takes you cannot
play up six immediately as a six pawn
Hanks but what you can do is first
deflect this queen with h5 now White
Queen has to stay in protection of d4
square so the only logical response is
Queen to D Vern afterwards no price for
the gassing Black's
next move yup it's very obvious epochs
well black has two choices amongst them
f4 is a pretty bad one even though that
pawn chain looks so impressive Black has
this lethal response Queen to b6 and
white get immediately losing position he
cannot play Bishop to e3 due to the
simple move Queen captures b2 so that's
not a choice
and if white tries to defend the d4 pawn
with Knight to e2 then the simplest
continuation is pawn takes pawn takes
and here there are many good choices
rook captures have fun or nightcaps ePHI
but I like this simple move Bishop
captures e5 which gives once again black
a healthy pawn advantage last but not
least what happens if Queen to d3
attacking on g6 well we have no issues
we can first easily defend this bond
with King to at 7 and now White has to
play f4 as after he kept us up 6 and
Queen kept it up 6 once again the d4
pawn is a goner
so that's not a good choice for the
white let's see what happens after the
move f4
well after that the task is very easy we
are going to capture on e5 and after F
captures ePHI the same old story with
just a few twists first we are going to
take this route and after King takes now
comes Queen to b6 attacking twice on d4
Bishop to e3 is the only logical reply
after this black has this decisive move
in the picture
rook to FA check Kiley note King cannot
go to even or e2 as Queen to b2 is
very strong reply so accordingly white
King has to go to the G 1 square
afterwards the star move from the black
camp Bishop 26 destroying the defender
of d4 square I did this position against
a 2100 rated opponent and after Bishop
takes King takes black is threatening to
pawns so my opponent wisely defended
with Queen to d2 defending b2 as well as
giving me a check I played King to g7
and now he thought that he is back in
the game with rook to d1 perishing every
single threat but what he missed is yup
the simple but very effective Knight
captures a fire
so you can see in all this lines black
image with an extra pawn and even though
sometimes white concede he cannot do
anything about it in this game probably
my opponent thought that this is not
possible due to the Knight to a4 move
but after Queen to c6
he realized that he has lost the ball
for absolutely no compensation that's it
guys I hope you enjoy and learn this
mini informative video on how to play
against 3 c3 Sicilian remember when you
reach this critical position no matter
whatever why plays play this team attic
break ab6
and once you reach this position no
matter how they were white wriggles with
accurate play and a one-point advantage
you always get a driving seat on the
ball well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on this and I'll meet you in my
next episode very soon bye and take care
you